la pandémie est venu annuler deux coups
secs le printemps dernier la saison des
érablières et ce sera le cas presque
assurément encore cette année de
nouvelles mesures des deux toutefois du
gouvernement pourrait rendre la saison
des sucres un peu moins amère
stéphanie laurin et fondatrice de
l'association des salles de réception et
érablière du québec et directeur général
de la cabane à sucre le chalet des
érables bonsoir en sort votre
association a publié une étude de thé
dresser un portrait quand même assez
sombre des effets de la pandémie sur les
érablières d'abord un petit portrait là
il ya eu beaucoup de fermetures au cours
des derniers mois oui exactement je vous
le confirme
il faut comprendre qu'au québec nous
sommes près de 7400 producteurs de sirop
d'érable
de ce nombre nous sommes seulement 200
kavanagh suka propager les savoir faire
agricole autour de l'érable donc sur les
200 camarades du québec je vous confirme
qu'à l'heure actuelle malheureusement
nous en avons déjà perdu une quarantaine
ou qu'on va donc ça aille vite et
d'autres se posent sérieusement de
grandes questions pour la saison qui va
bientôt s'amorcer vos établissements qui
sont en zone orange par exemple ce qui
peuvent accueillir des clients
oui les établissements en zone orange
auront le droit d'ouvrir leur salle à
manger mais il sera très compliqué pour
les gens de s'y rendre parce qu'on peut
changer de son bien évidemment mais nous
sommes tout de même très envie de saison
des sucres et inventé le gouvernement où
s'annoncent headley de 50 mille dollars
pour appuyer l'initiative ma cabane à la
maison c'est d'ailleurs le logo qui a
derrière vous parlez nous un peu de ce
projet qui est lancée la semaine
prochaine mais en fait il faut
comprendre le câprier la saison des
sucres que nous avons traversée en 2020
les cabanes à sucre du québec nous nous
sommes regroupés dans une association
dans l'objectif de comprendre les
programmes disponibles et deux de
trouver oreille attentive et après
plusieurs échanges on a réalisé qu'on
devait se préparer en vue de la saison
des sucres 2021 parce que tout allait
jouer dans les douze semaines que nous
allions avoir et c'est depuis septembre
dernier que nous sommes impliqués dans
un projet de la cité qui se nomme
mcavan à la maison que nous allons
présenter dès jeudi le 22 février
prochain à tous les québécois
alors c'est vraiment de coeur que nous
allons vous offrir une saison des sucres
dans l'objectif de préserver la
tradition
nous espérons que tout le monde seront
au rendez vous des livres damman mais
dans tous les cas nous sommes prêts et
on est très à peu près soyons contraints
ce sera des commandes pour emporter
c'est ça oui exactement sur une même
plateforme
donc le site mcavan à la maison les gens
vont se géolocaliser sélectionner leur
cavale avec préféré est bien évidemment
passer leurs commandes pour ensuite en
prendre possession
dès lundi plusieurs autres surprises
vont être présentés jarre est vraiment
le goût de vous en dire davantage mais
on vous réserve quelques surprises la
voit ici à tous les québécois mais juste
sur les commandes s'effacer c'est
possible parce qu'on fait ça dans les
restaurants depuis presqu'un alors des
commandes à emporter puis de la
livraison de dans une cabane à sucre ça
va être possible de faire ça des
commandes à emporter
oui effectivement nous sommes prêts et
on a pensé à tout donc nous avons des
boîtes isothermes pour bien évidemment
le transport nous avons des contenants
tout effet 100 % au québec 100 %
recyclable et alors nous sommes hyper
fier de ce projet leurs pions de penser
à yoff surprise qui va venir avec
l'achat de la voix pour apporter un
petit peu de bonheur dans chaque foyer
le gouvernement du québec a annoncé
aussi que chaque cabane pourrait toucher
jusqu'à 50000 dollars en appui
il ya un programme aussi pour couvrir
les frais d'électricité c'est essentiel
soit pour vous il plus qu'essentiel en
fait je vous confie qu actuellement les
cabanes à sucre du québec le père que
nous sommes avons traversé l'année la
plus difficile depuis déjà vingt deux
générations et les érablières ont
parfois même des difficultés à pouvoir
mettre le chauffage dans leur
établissement
donc j'ai certains propriétaires qui
travaillent actuellement au froid parce
qu'ils ont malheureusement aucune
liquidités pour payer les factures
alors ça vient mettre un petit peu un
bon sur l'année qu'on vient de traverser
ça nous donne de l'espoir dans la saison
qui va arriver qu'on peut se concentrer
à faire une petite recette à vic
beaucoup d'amour est ce que d'autres
cabane à sucre vous pensez qu'ils
pourraient fermer qui sont à risque en
ce moment je vous confirme que certains
et postures de se rendre au printemps
ils ont tout misé dans le projet ma
cabane à la maison il faut comprendre
que nous sommes des compétiteurs
habituellement est là et nous sommes
rendus des amis donc c'est vraiment un
réseau d'entrailles incroyable est ce
que tous vont passer au travers de la
prochaine saison
je ne crois pas mais on aura tout essayé
cependant et savent au moins nous avoir
permis de se rendre au printemps avec un
petit peu d'espoir un petit peu de
bonheur
puis on va tous ces canaux pour nous on
veut changer nous aider on voit que
c'est apporter du bonheur dans les
foyers du québec
d'autant qu'on arrive à des niveaux
records de production en ce moment je
vous souhaite dans la mesure du possible
une bonne saison
merci madame l'heureux pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit